kryp Key's theory of Truth aims to
unravel semantic paradoxes such as the
Liar's Paradox by building a hierarchy
of stages reminiscent to tari and
Russell's type Theory kryy distinguishes
himself from tarski by deploying a fixed
Point theorem across a hierarchy of
stages to assign truth values sentences
might obtain or modify their truth
values as the sequence of stages
progresses the distinction in kryp model
is between grounded and ungrounded
sentences grounded sentences have
determinate truth values so either
whether true or false while ungrounded
ones like the liar sentence claiming its
own falsehood don't have a truth value
at least not at certain stages we talk
more about kryy and krippenstein here in
this podcast with gome Chomsky Link in
the description subscribe to get
notified by the way we've spoken to
Chomsky several times on the topics of
philosophy of language and meaning and
artificial intelligence such as can
computers be conscious what does it even
mean for a computer to think